how do others in the industry relate to
your work ethic I don't think I'm crazy
I mean I don't get it done I can't sleep
now I'm gonna how tired I know if I
don't get it done my work that day I
can't sleep so I'm worried about it the
next day and okay how many hours so I
have to get it you know just because
it's in and so I meditate and the
meditation helps me but they respect it
because I don't stop because I'm super
super super prepared enough to guess so
I said a week before we shoot they have
every shot every single setup and shut
of the movie on a piece of paper all
they gotta do is follow the map that
I've created I'm not saying they don't
have the freedom within that context to
say hey but what about this what about
that right but you have a map so they
respect that familywize they she's wise
never been married
it's I've been very selfish and the
women in my life have hated that because
of my work ethic I try not to be my work
home but next day I'm gonna go prepare
it I want to I want to be able to so
okay let's have a few moments of
camaraderie and whatever okay great I go
work on the script and that's the most
that's not the most comforting of things
in a relationship because we owe a each
other the attention that each other
needs and I've voice struggled with that
I always have in relationships I might
and the other thing it sounds crazy but
being a black man in this business
I felt I always had to be better not as
good but better because as good is not
good enough it's always paranoid I could
be super duper duper super prepared I
have to you know some speaking for more
than myself as an individual speaking
for culture because we're judged like
that you know oh I didn't know there was
gonna be that good cuz he's back
you see he's a big guy you know never
want to be a B never want to be an a a
plus plus it takes I almost think much
when I work it's always in my mind I
can't explain it exists and this stuff I
shot the day before I know I know I
could have done it better if I had few
more hours
I just wanted to be better I want to be
my legacy that it's excellent it's
something that I gave a thousand percent
but um it's crazy too because you know
it's I could always be better you know
it's it so it could be different but
it's kind of like a little neurotic type
deal but it's Who I am as a creative
person some people know the level of
intimacy they're comfortable with and
I'm not talking about physical intimacy
I'm just talking about being amongst
people and some people are better just
focusing on a career I think they just
know that about themselves and
unfortunately he's gotten a bad rap but
if some people know that you know what a
career is the most important thing to me
and if I if I get someone into my world
I may end up hurting them because I'm
not gonna be available for them how can
they be okay with that that's a good
question
it's a good question one or two choices
I'm going to satisfy your needs and
ignore the truth of my own I'm gonna
satisfy my needs and ignore the truth of
the relationships AIDS
I tried this once excite like the person
so much I tried not taking a job and
staying in the house and watching the
flowers grow and doing all the things
she liked and I she was happy but
there's the truth that I I i realized
something after a few months of feeling
resentment and that eventually
manifesting itself so was it i was i was
fulfilling the desires
it wasn't happy because i was lacking
something
I've always been a worker I always
wanted to work Oh work stimulates me it
gives you fulfillment it's not that I
need romantic fulfill make everybody
else I need love and caring like
everybody else but loving caring without
me feeling engaged in something I'm so
passionate about which is my work if I
gave that up I it's not good for a
relationship with me and it's in that
that's what that's what's so difficult
you know it's I think I suppose well my
goddaughter because it's like you know
since three we spent so much time
together and I helped raise her and
spoiled her and everything you know
because I don't think it was there
enough I just kept doing things things
things we worked it out of course but
it's like she's traveled around the
world many places and everything and
that's all good but she was saying look
think we just sit down and just meditate
we just sit down and just talk yes I do
that but I got everybody saying we were
safe 74 gonna be 75 February 26 we have
to still be working I said well it's am
I gonna do
retire just you know just sit in the
porch in the beach watch the flowers
grow and and enjoy the air and
so that's the rest of my wife huh
enjoying the flowers suppose I could
discover how the flowers amazing I
suppose I could discover where the sky
came from where I suppose I could
discover where air comes from and the
source of reality and film it
I mean I mean one of this my heroes of
discovery he's older than me Oh some
working freemen with his new network and
and this whole probably about God you
know who and where is God what is God
where I mean these amazing thinkers cuz
if I those questions himself just the
his brilliance of going into those
topics and understanding God what does
that mean to cultures around the world
that's fascinating to me but it he still
has an open mind he still wants to learn
and know that's inspiring I watched last
night
Terry Bradshaw and the boxer I forgot
his name but so struggling called better
late than never
and these four older men they're in
their 70s and some in their eighties and
well this one young guy the son I think
Terry brought show calls with them
around the world and they visit places
they always wanted to visit before they
died but they do it together
it's funny it's inspiring it's powerful
because they don't stop they just know
before I
I got a certain amount of time left I'm
gonna do everything everyone to do and
that there's something about that's
wonderful
it's beautiful cuz they don't I'm
retiring and I'm gonna lay up and get it
and just watch the birds go by
they're flying the birds so it feels a
fly okay I love it that's life
a lot of my friends work at jobs they
hate for 35 years they work every day
but to be admired health insurance car
payments house note send the kids to
college all the dreams they had they
gave him up when they were 20 was they
had children they retire and there may
be dead and five to nine years it's not
what I wanted it's not what I want I
hope I don't mind probably dying I said
you know something I don't know I'm just
saying only God knows that but I mean I
just want to do something I wanted to do
and these days how was Steven Spielberg
and George Lucas and Clint Eastwood they
no stop
you